bueno ec emoción estar aquí
tengo mucho miedo esto de abrir el
evento no sé si es lo mío
bueno espero que al cabo del día todos
en contra hemos con un punto
e interesante de acuerdo a lo que fuimos
aprender olp
por cierto bajón publicidad que es una
profesión con una reputación no os
demasiado buena y de hecho
pues ésta esta cita como chiste interno
incluso en el mundo publicitario no
perdí a mi madre que trajo un
publicidad ella piensa que tocó el
piano en un burdel
aún así
yo voy hablar de publicidad
no tanto de lo que la publicidad 3
si te lo que a mí me gustaría que
fuera
va ser un país como méxico
i bases tasarla en una invitación qué
voy a dejar para el final
pero sobre todo en dos ejes de
documentación
una de ellas es en la oportunidad que
tienen las marcas
d
trascender más allá de los productos o
servicios queremos presentar los
usuarios y la necesidad para ello
de crear talentos multidisciplinares
para poder acometer esta tarea no
creo que esto es necesario
y creo que es interesante
desde el punto de vista de que no
ocurran méjico lo que ocurrió a este
chico en una carta que envía un
político en españa
en la cual él contaba cómo el estado
español que invirtió x cantidad de
dinero en becas el
y al final él nunca encontró un
trabajo en españa
de lo que había estudiado en un tubo
que mirar y ahora vive en bélgica es un
ciudadano propio en bélgica
dejando de lado el tema del dinero y las
becas
creo que méxico es un país con un
talento creativo extraordinario pero
creo que su talento
no lo estamos cultivando lo estamos
cuidando y ese talento lo que va a
ocurrir es que para imitar otras
latitudes
se va a estancar
y semejante de paterna podrían o no
por cierto en cuestión un muñequito es
una de las cosas que más
atesoró es de lo más valioso que
tenemos y mi casa
en el fuego él probablemente es una de
las cosas que salvaría
i y es un presupuesto que hicieron los
alumnos de la escuela vital interés
para todos los profesores que les dimos
clase entre la segunda generación
el mundial nos encontramos en el
escritorio para mí tiene mucho valor
no sólo por el detalle dejé de hacerlo
sino porque a todos nos pusieron el gol
quitó una caja
i n en la caja no se ve muy bien pero la
caja está escrita di aquí cada uno
expresó sus sentimientos de lo que
había aprendido en los tres meses que
habían pasado con nosotros durante el
curso
a mí me llena de emoción
por el hecho de por cien lo que
expresaban edad gracias por el prelado
perspicacia tal pero también gracias
por el lado personal porque creo que
todos decían que se sentía
sorprendidos de
lo grande que era su visión de las
cosas después de tres meses con
nosotros no
i atesora mucho esta caja por qué él
representa para mí
un momento 1 un objeto único que
representan momentos de mi vida
el digital e intereses una escuela que
fundó la agencia en la que trabajó
bien queríamos hacer crecer la agencia
buscamos talento no lo encontramos
decidimos que la mejor formar los
entonces decidimos ofrecer cursos
gratuitos para el talento para que el
talento se acerque
lo formamos y una vez que está formado
por cinco sus de tres meses algunos se
quedan en la agencia y otros se marchan
por cien pero menos lleva una semilla de
cambiar allá donde va no
por ciento y la docencia es una de
tantas cosas que
esa es la vida soy un conglomerado
extraño de muchas cosas porque yo sé
que la publicidad por el mundo de la
tecnología
reside estudios ingeniero así que ya
hacía cosas que la gente utilizaba pero
un día me resultó más interesante
preguntarme por qué la gente usaría
bono
algo que ya había hecho
entonces descubrí que necesitaba más
respuestas para responder a esa pregunta
pues decidí estudiar antropología
por cieno entender por qué porque a mí
lo que me gusta es
el arquitectura
y hay un tema muy interesante
que es el de su extranjero en méxico
y los extranjeros nunca somos capaces de
esto explicarle a los mexicanos la
fascinación que en méxico ejerce sobre
nosotros
envíe descubrí que la fascinación
es la forma de auto defensa
para interpretar finalmente imágenes
como éstas antillano es
creo que representaba el méxico mágico
no es una casa cuyo primer piso que una
puerta que da al vacío
y si te toca comprenderlo me explota la
cabeza pero desde la fascinación de eta
es méjico digo basta sido útil
y 2do disfrutó no
saltillo es relevante para mí porque es
donde está la sede de la agencia en la
que trabajó grupo doble uve hace cuatro
años
en en el primer puesto fue para marcar
por eso era antes descubrí entonces
que las noches de publicidad son largas
y eterna si hace falta
una válvula de escape para escapar de
entre los próximos minutos del asus
mental no
yo lo encontré en un cómic que se
llama caballo negro
que es una historia de
zombis amor no tiene sexo personajes
realmente bizarros esotéricos
y realmente como desahogo a las ocho de
la mañana es un buen principio muy
valioso no
y lo que nos pasó fue que estos años
después
haciendo campañas para eso era antes y
demás
nos vimos un día en esta lista
habíamos ido a la la cuarta agencia
más premiada del mundo
desde saltillo
y pongo esta esta escuadra aquino para
decir mira qué bien sino más bien para
hacer factible el hecho de que
probablemente 99% de las personas que
están aquí desconocían este hecho y
lo normal es comprensible y admirables
que lo desconozca porque la publicidad
realmente no le interesa a nadie estos
son ingresos publicitarios do
una risa de su piso rita la pole
bueno porque haciendo campañas para eso
era antes con todo lo grande que es el
mundo de todos ustedes yo lo que hago es
intentar influir en este deseo una
decisión que tiene lugar
en este punto es espacio-tiempo
el pasillo de los desodorantes tu
farmacia guadalajara
es un poco triste no
y de eso tiene que ver mucho con el
hecho de cómo las marcas le hablará a
las personas nos mata solano las
personas no como personas y no como
números como tarjetas como consumidores
me parece una palabra
por primera vez lo que los banners en
facebook
son ejemplo representativo de lo mal que
está la publicidad se supone que todo
lo que te sale es preferente arcos que
te pueden interesar pero a mí nunca me
interesa nada no
y creo que
el contexto está producida funciona
lo podía explicar con ésta pequeña
historia está destinada a aportar
del cuarto del pos pital en el que
falleció mi padre
i
en 2008 lee
en contra un cáncer de páncreas ya en
avanzado estado
tres meses después
él falleció y durante todo el proceso
mi pregunta era de madera por qué no
entonces del
los médicos lo que nos contestaban era
un razonamiento
médico-científico de por qué la
enfermedad así como se desarrolla ve
como el organismo
si va habiendo aceptado
pero yo no era lo que preguntar
yo me preguntaba por qué tiene este
cómo se desarrolla su preguntábamos
bien
porque a mi padre porque me toca a mí
vivir esto no
de alguna manera
aunque los dos
respondíamos aún por qué
no hablamos el mismo idioma
y yo encontré
en cotejo
emocional e intelectual en una movida
que se llama de fontaine su historia de
amor muy hermosa blake un doctor
encuentra prácticamente la receta para
la vida eterna
para salvar a su esposa que tiene un
tumor cerebral pero siempre llega
segundos tarde a salvarla
hasta que al final comprende que la
única manera de volver a estar con ella
no es ser inmortal intenta resucitar la
sino que es lo que hay que hacer es
dejarse morir
para tras reunirse con ella no
i de alguna manera siempre pensé que
esto es una metáfora de cómo funciona
la publicidad la publicidad de las
marcas
hablan como sus médicos que hablaban a
mí
y contratar a las agencias para que
transmitan ese mensaje
pero los porqués que la gente necesita
no nos responden ellos no
pspc sería interesante que la
publicidad hiciera ante el vehículo
entre lo que unos quieren y lo que otros
realmente necesitan
más aún en un país como méxico donde
uno encuentra fotos como ésta
el que dice se prohíbe fumar en toda la
estación
este señor gobernador el simit haedo
es un la sociedad mexicana está
completamente descartada la clase
política por desgracia
nadie de los políticos como agentes de
un cambio que me pueda beneficiar
a mí como persona no
y creo que se destinen tries asimismo al
final nos hace mal porque este cartel
dice más mal del que lo puso que los
políticos es como de
renunció por completo a interactuar con
ellos
entonces ella le pregunté
no sería interesante si la publicidad
no sólo
posiciones inter consumo no sería
interesante si la publicidad pudiera
recuperar espacios como construir
valores toda transacción entre persona
y marca a mí me dicen dinero seguro
no podría la gente hacia la publicidad
con la misma expectación con la que
entra
a una sala de cine
yo creo que sí pero teniendo eso en
cuenta creo que las marcas su visión es
como únicamente de profit y beneficio
propio y creo que no es también del
contexto en el que viven con lo cual en
esta frase de la policía no se puede
dejar en manos de las marcas
ni de sus agencias haciendo publicidad
para ellas no por cien
porque las marcas lo que piensan este
todo lo que queremos irnos al mundial de
fútbol y es como código de compra
sitio web entra una rifa
y te vas al mundial
piensa que todos queremos ir a
sudáfrica lima cita sean o no quiera
sudáfrica yo quiero ir
alonso a comprar mi desayuno
y de los que puedes encontrar
periódicos puestos de nota roja
yo personalmente lo salvó resto
min me resulta grotesco la forma en que
es trivializar algo tan
el prólogo
es importante como éste la muerte no el
pero de vez en cuando pasan cosas
interesantes
en saltillo
y bien bien
por ejemplo esta noticia no
onu que un tipo se va de fiesta con sus
amigos o cementerio
por grupo
perón
i los amigos de dar una paliza a los
propios han muerto y lo entierran pero
no estaba muerto ese tipo se levantó de
la tumba
y causa gran susto a unas once metas
es decir caótica sigue con la historia
de los prófugos al día siguiente la
noticia sigue con fuma o no también de
hecho llega todos los días
y me decía el señor de los ojos
porque comprar periódicos siempre habla
mal de dios que no puedo quedarme sin
saber cómo termina la historia
el quedarme sin saber cómo termina la
historia es interesante porque pero
también hay necesidad yo no quería ir
al mundial quería saber cómo terminaba
la historia de los prófugos esto se lo
descubrí hace tres meses tenía una
ipad en
ibiza er
hace tres semanas que no lo uso
i la mente pienso que el valor de las
cosas no es el qué sin el dinero sin el
valor de cuánto uno las tiene por ese
precio que pagamos
más por tener antes visto en esta pista
favoritos
pese a que aún hay paz no está
abusando y dije bueno voy a intentar
conseguir
algo a cambio de la paz es destacable
para mí tuvo ofertas como
variopintas como una cita que ofrecía
30 días de sexo a cambio de la paz y le
pregunté qué para qué lo quería y
dijo que era para su novia que amaba
mucho
pero al final lo que ocurrió fue que n
me escribió jorge cortés un lustrador
de monterrey autor de un cómic
el que se llevaba a cabo en el operativo
en el que participaron varios
y seguro que ganas tengo para contar
cómo termina en un cómic que yo leía
vi a un intercambio que no se puede
pagar con dinero y creo que después de
la publicación ofrecerle a la gente
cosas que no pueden comprar con dinero
sino más bien sueños como éste
aramburu por el suizo eskil físico dijo
james michetti
ahora mismo
todo eso ahora los protocolos es una
iniciativa de orden superior telefónico
el reino unido en el cual lo que se
hacía era conté daban conciertos por
ciento exclusivos de artistas muy
expertos mundiales
en los cuales
no podías comprar los coach los boletos
tenías que hacer cuatro horas de
voluntariado en zonas desfavorecidas de
londres
y entonces te ganabas los boletos pero
además con el agrado el añadido de que
esto estaba recogiendo escombros
de repente la artista que va a tocar el
concierto estaba recogiendo escombros
contigo con lo cual por sonora concepto
sino convivir con él cuatro horas
eso es algo que no se puede pagar con
dinero
esencialmente
lo que a mí me movería no tira al
maldito mundial de fútbol no
alguien puede pensar a buenas que los
ingleses son muy organizados y muy
formales y demás y bueno puede ser todo
el mundo protesta chica hora jimena
navarrete creo que se llama
es la
la actual miss universo
por cien lo que mucha gente no sabe es
que jimena navarrete hace cuatro años
ganaba
un concurso de pasarelas y motorizado
por una marca de sobrantes no digo que
esto sea causa consecuencia pero
probablemente este momento en 2006 tiene
que ver con el momento en 2010
entonces me pregunté si las marcas
hacen algo que puede ser común inició
una plataforma para que alguien consiga
ser miss universo porque las marcas no
se preguntan en
a lo mejor puede que sí
no lo sé lo que sí sé es que para
que esta plataforma tuviera
un trasfondo real
no pasa con cáncer publicidad porque la
publicidad
ejem la publicidad
y eso nos lleva al pasillo desodorantes
de forma segura la jara
y eso es lo que aprendimos en la escuela
dando clases el hecho de que no hay que
ver a la gente por lo que hace sino por
lo que la gente realmente es eso genera
resultados interesantes por ejemplo que
tengo
ap y que está por ahí arriba profesor
de escuela conmigo
y varios alumnos de las tres
generaciones que han pasado por la
escuela todos ellos tienen como perfiles
de marketing y publicidad y es por eso
por lo que entran a la escuela pero
cuál es el
lo que genera de ahí
más publicidad que a nadie le interesa
no
pero qué pasa si vemos a la gente por
lo que realmente disfruta haciendo que
es lo que la gente se hace lo que la
gente hace
pensemos que picar los mercadólogos y
arquitecto
la otra sala llena de valet
el otro es músico y demás si ven los
perfiles probablemente el resultado de
eso
sea mucho más interesante es un dato
algo indefinido no se llama
pero creo que potencialmente es mucho
más interesante
y eso genera proyectos como éste que
hicieron los alumnos de la escuela
en los cuales en el cual
otro de los alumnos encerraron durante
dos días consecutivos
sin dormir a dibujar todo lo que la
gente les envía por twitter facebook y
por ebay
metros unas cámaras web los grababa
neto de estaban los cuatro que dibujaban
pero también había un equipo de
personas detrás revisando las cámaras
de la trasmisión
con un centro de control viendo cuáles
lo siguiente que llegaba
y al final se dieron cuenta
de que todos están participando en el
proyecto
haciendo algo distinto
de aquello por lo que los lleva a la
escuela y además eran 15 de perfiles
distintos
y creo que esto es interesante porque la
forma en que el público se conectó fue
espectacular tuvieron cientos de miles
de visitas
cientos de miles interacciones
y demostraron que para conectarse con la
gente de forma honesta
no siempre hace falta una asencio de
publicidad
todo es que es una gran época para
trabajar en publicidad por eso como
herramienta
pese a todo que es una buena época para
no estar seguros pasota mente de nada
especialmente en el lado de la
formación no
eso dice mucho de su mundo tecnológico
por ciento y digital y que no estamos
deshumanizando yo creo que es todo lo
contrario creo que somos más humanos
que nunca y la tecnología lo que hace
es
incentivar eso habló sea supersónica
creo que nunca las fotos de una fiesta
en facebook serán tan divertido
como estar en la propia cisternas que
las fotos se tomaron lo que sí creo que
permite la tecnología es que este es un
mundo mestizo de generaciones de razas
que géneros y disciplinas y eso lo que
nos permite es ser un poco más leonardo
sosa ver mucho de algo pero saber un
poquito de otras muchas cosas para ser
mejores en eso que somos
y a la hora de cultivar el talento es
una gran ayuda pública la gente lo que
es
icíar lemas cosas para que sean mejores
en méxico por ejemplo
cuando fútbol americano los jugadores
entrenan vale para ejercitar su
coordinación o su flexibilidad
y sobre todo su disciplina y el respeto
por el contrario no
y eso como recompensa creo que nos trae
por ejemplo del rejuvenecer
yo me siento ahora mucho más joven que
hace diez años
y crece esta frase creo que lo resume
muy bien no tengo 40 años tengo 18 con
22 experiencia
3 deba contó final de mi disertación
este es un poema de maría zambrano que
era una solista española muy reconocida
y habla de que cada cosa preciosa que
tenemos
en algún momento fue otra cosa ya que
sin cargo de forjar la
o de sembrarlas y creo que
todos vinimos fuentes
buscando n
ideas que mañana llevarnos
a nuestros lugares para poder donar un
cambio
yo creo que es muy interesante pero creo
que no deberíamos perder de vista el
hecho de que eta para que sus ideas se
plasmen
hace falta primero encontrar un talento
en el que tomarlas
entonces
por ciento básicamente
en mi invitación era a la vez que
el talento
así como estos elementos el aire
oo a
por ciento
está por todas partes creo que el
talento nos rodea
y todos ustedes están rodeados de vital
interés empezando por la persona que
tienes en total la butaca de al lado
pero hace falta que empecemos a mirar a
las demás personas por lo que son y no
por lo que hacen
y de esa manera con las ideas que aquí
todos nos iremos hoy
probablemente podamos dar un cambio
primero pequeño porque si nos llevamos
todo intentamos hacerlo en grande
no vamos a poder porque estamos solos
pero detonando pequeño grupo de
personas a las que señale algo y
recibir algo a cambio nos va a permitir
que sí seamos unos agentes de cambio
que podamos aprender y finalmente éstas
meditación para todos hoy el hecho de
si ustedes quieren cambiar las cosas
antes han de dejarse sorprender
defensas aprender para poder sorprender
después y creo casi todos tenemos un
mejor lugar para vivir para nosotros y
para los que vengan tras